guys Christ DC comedy.com for Ticky
wikies I'm in Salt Lake City and Denver
this weekend all the shows are sold out
I appreciate the good fans here the only
places left to see me January 12th El
kahon San Diego January 13th the wilter
Los Angeles and then we have February
2nd in Nashville Tennessee February 3rd
in Washington DC and February 8th in
Reno Nevada those are my last dates
Chris DC comedy.com for Ticky wikies I'm
really proud of this hour so come see it
come see it live
all right guys I have one date left of
this two-year tour it's in wils Bear
Pennsylvania uh December 16th there's
only about 100 tickets left so get on
that if you want to see me perform this
m show for the very last time other than
that new year new tour with the guys
from the Impractical Jokers we're going
everywhere we're going to Highland
California Las Vegas Nevada Tempe
Arizona and we're also going to Miami on
that Cruise January 22nd and then we're
doing Hollywood Florida Tampa Cincinnati
Youngstown Ohio uh we're doing Foxwoods
Atlanta Georgia Mobile Alabama and a
bunch more dates are going to be added
just go to
impracticaljokers.com for those tickets
uh uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey babe hey bab hey bab
hey bab hey bab when the Sun beats down
and burs guar Up on the Roof
and your shes get so hot you wish your
tired feet with
fireproof under the hay
babe down by the
sea on a blanket with
my is where I'll
be under the hay babe out of the sun
under the hay babe we'll be Happ having
some fun under the head babe people
walking above under the head babe we'll
be falling in love under the hey babe
heyy babe now that's how you come back
together we are back folks I didn't lie
to y'all I told y'all we was coming back
he he told y'all he he told y'all we was
coming back I told y'all y'all didn't
want to listen you're bad yall didn't
want to listen
your back your back down maybe 150 lb
hair up to the roof right now you look
amazing it's almost like you've turned
into a beautiful woman thank you so
much hold on uh now man I feel like a
woman um you look fantastic now let's
let's get to the bottom of is it fasting
is it fact is it is it hellofresh what
is it uh it
is uh eating healthier eating making
better choices and not eating as much
over a long period of time or is it
diarrhea from the anxiety of the special
both because somebody just shot a comedy
special and let me tell you word on the
street is it was amazing wow thanks so
much heard is it word on the street word
on the street we heard from um I heard
from Ari that it was uh fantastic um I
saw Adam Ray post a comment um I spoke
to your manager who said it was
unbelievable Chris Johnson was like dude
and then you sent me the voice memo yeah
and said that it was one of because
here's the thing with comedy specials a
lot of people are putting them out now
and maybe they're special maybe they're
not but you actually captured a special
night I hope so with a special crowd I
hope so and when I say that means most
of the crowd was they were had special
needs yes we did we did one for charity
and then one one for them one for me
because that's the thing is you know
every everyone's doing Special South
told me want to do something different
so he had the entire audience was
actually special that's correct which is
which is something totally different and
that's special we did two I did mine
which is called uh terrified and I did
that one which is called literally
special L right yes yes and that's a
beautiful thing and that's why I think
you know people have keep referring to
as the people's champ we did it at the
Vic in Chicago as if I didn't say it
enough over the last [__] year but uh
yeah it was good you know my one thing
was like am I going to get an audience
that has been as good as the audiences
on the tour like I wanted to be the best
representation of a set you know and
they came man Chicago shout out to
Chicago man they came out Chicago if you
if number one I think it I think I you
know close to New York so I'm going to
say New York is number one but Chicago
is number two Chicago might be one New
York is 1 a and Chicago might be 1B that
city is phenomenal I love Chicago dude
dud I found out there 71 neighborhoods
in Chicago wow 71 I went to two or three
and uh you know it's it's just I love I
love it I love that the river runs right
through that thing I love that that
you're right by the water there all the
different neighborhoods the food is good
I love the sports in that town it's just
a great town guys send us a video and
whoever wins this I'm prepared to say
this whoever wins this whoever can
actually do this we will fly them out
and they can be they can watch a live
hey bab from the new studio send us a
video you can send it to at heyab or hey
bayod at gmail let's see what this is
going to be 71 without taking a breath
name all 7 one neighborhoods in Chicago
without saying um once so just rapid
fire like if it was Queens Brooklyn
manhatt s Island in the Bronx I don't
know if it's doable but how do we know
they're not
reading if we catch you fraudulent we
will fly you in and not let you know we
caught you and then we'll billy club you
when you get exactly if you if we catch
that as fraud and what we'll do is yes
we'll we'll we'll create we'll gal you
we'll gal you you know what that is
right G um come on guli no uh Nancy
carrian oh Tanya hard Harding that's it
yeah Tanya Harding is that not crazy
that's nuts can you can you refresh me
on that okay did Tanya Harding know it
was going to happen or did GLI take
madis into his own hands to be like a a
boyfriend that she that would turn her
on first of all guli is one of the
funniest one of the funniest H names
doesn't it feel like a like a like a
like a nickname for like an ass yeah
like gely hey you go SL me right on the
gal this guy's being a galali yeah um so
what happened was is Nancy carrian was
an amazing like it in the
galali there it is so so what two things
are amazing about this one the actual
event which um Nancy carrian um was was
Billy clubbed in her knees before a was
before wild before like a skating event
and she was like why why that's like
that iconic thing the second part of
this story that's amazing is 20 years
later when um Margot Robbie played her
in the movie Tanya yeah Tanya Harding
got a standing ovation I know and so
it's just Society it shows you like the
fabric we're terrible it doesn't make
any sense we need to do better where
you're like are you a good guy or a bad
I'm going care who we raise up we don't
care I'll go the other way so it's
symmetry we don't clear who we glorify
anymore no no but listen let's just go
back and talk about this on a broad
level how insane is it that there's
figure skaters out there right that are
excellent that craft and they're going
to go into competition together and one
of them is like she's too good and this
guy with this big goddamn stash gets a
billy club and imagine being there he
just walked up to a woman that had
skates on that was also by the way an
accomplished I mean this is which this
is Olympics right Tanya Harding was
accomplishing her own right yeah this is
Olympics right he goes to an Olympian an
Olympian whose life has been to train to
keep their body as their Temple to make
sure her legs her an her joints are all
collaged up they're the best they could
possibly be she's at the peak she's
competing at the peak of competition in
the entire world this this just jamoke
he takes a billy club he approaches her
and starts beating on her legs with a
billy club and think about her like
there's no way if you asked her that day
or before that in her life name
something that you think in a billion
eons would never happen you she' be like
well just on the ice one day and one man
comes up to me with a billy club and
just starts whacking me about the knees
and thighs and legs yes like there's no
way and then as she's getting it what
and then also hello if you're going to
Target her ankles and legs and knees
they're going to know it has something
to do with the competition why not just
whack her in the face knock her out then
you don't know if it's has something to
do with something else she's still going
to be swollen maybe a little loopy she's
not going to be the best in the triple
axles right why hit her in the in The
Shins yeah why why not just do something
else completely why not poison her food
why not exactly and did it come from I I
forget did it come from Tanya I think it
was Tanya Harding being extremely
jealous it was her boyfriend right let's
let's read into this please could you
imagine as you were walking out to do
your special at the Vic theater Joe came
out and clubbed your knce Joe came out
and just clubbed cuz they were friends
right were they knew each other it would
be like if Joe came out and clubbed your
knees before your special Club my mouth
clubbed your mouth before I'm like oh
training and knocked all your teeth out
you're like why I no no Joe G didn't do
it Joe g hi someone else Jo H Joe G Jo
it would be like Joe g h ven to
Jo so so so she knew about it so did
they go they got expelled did she did
Nancy end up competing did he go to jail
and did she get disbarred from the
Olympics we'll find out in a moment
after this right after this yeah um I
think well first of all if I'm not
mistaken wasn't G LLY played by our boy
Paul Walker Hower I think he might have
been it's not Paul Walker Hower no it's
Walter Paul Walter
Hower no that's Paul Walker and doie
Hower had a kid that's that's a good
character on Paul Walker Hower um yes so
I what I want to say the story is and
again you guys have the internet right
in front of you you can tell us how
wrong we are but what I think happened
is she got clubbed Nancy caring got
clubbed seal like a seal could never
compete again or competed in like you
know the not not real Olympic events yes
and then Tanya Harding got disqualified
tried to say it wasn't her and they were
like but your boyfriend did it and she
was like yeah but that could be a
coincidence and and then I think they I
want to read this yes I and I think that
she was never allowed to skate again I
want to say she went to jail Tanya
Harden well I think she should have no
look see yeah see the yeah why yeah and
and he did it in the locker room why
does this woman have a stethoscope what
are you going to do well just to see if
the knees are okay
we still have heart we still have blood
flow to the
knee um so all right let's let's can we
do you mind if we narrate this from the
beginning letar I really don't know yes
let's narrate it and and and and who do
you want to be um well actually no this
is just a report is that the is that the
top of the article by the way this is
People magazine my dream in life is to
one day be in People magazine it's all
I've ever wanted oh I've been in that
it's not a big deal no but you were in
faces in the crowd celebrities they're
just like us I don't remember see cuz
that's something that used to always be
in my mother's bathroom and I remember
I'd be like a little kid in the bathroom
like reading People magazine celebrities
if you like get on the cover like I
don't I don't I think I was like they
did a I don't know I have no idea it is
a big deal okay I'd like to be like Time
Magazine Man of the Year that's that' be
nice it or sexiest fellow who get that
Esquire GQ should one of the Impractical
Jokers be People's sexiest man alive we
yeah we well they added Us in that issue
right I was in the issue of sexy being
love the one that Paul Paul Rd was on
the cover of and then did was it all
should one of you be well I actually say
yes yeah I don't think any of us should
be but but it was nice just to be
thought of who is the sexiest Joker
imagine we asked the crowd and like they
just had a resounding one name like 100%
Zer it's 100% one of them you could put
put a poll up who is the sexiest Joker
let's see I think it's going to I don't
know who it would be who the hell knows
I think every people always all have
their favorites um okay go ahead do baby
do all right so it was the sports
Scandal that the world 7 weeks before
the 1994 Olympic Winter Games Tanya
Harding skating rival Nancy carrian was
clubbed on the knee by an a salent a
well salent aent is fun it's a fun word
that's not used enough an a salent yeah
I was AED authorities soon determined
that Harding was involved and that her
ex-husband Jeff
guli it sounds like a made up last it
does it's like when you press for a name
and you're like I don't want to say my
name GLI Jeff GLI like if I asked my
8-year-old hey honey I want you to make
up a name of a really scary man go
g wait wait so uh it was our ex husband
then is that that's what that's implies
right I would he was already herx maybe
he was trying to he was trying to get
back and give her his own billy club
maybe there it is okay for the media the
narrative was perfect carrian was the
pretty poised innocent victim Harding
was the Rough Around the Edges a salent
as salent yes from the wrong side of the
track where was she from 8 Mile I think
she was from Detroit where was Tanya
Harding from I don't know decades
Robie did the tracks historically did
tracks divide classes of
neighborhoods why where do we get that
uh where we side of the tracks I I would
have to say that yes idian where did we
get that train tracks I would have to
say that I would think that train tracks
kind of was a dividing line in the
neighborhood um okay the expression
wrong side of tracks come from the idea
of a town divided by a railroad track in
1920 9 Thorn and my side Smith wrote in
most commuting towns there are always
two sides of which the tracks serve as a
line of demarcation there's the right
side and the wrong side but why did they
okay whatever whatever no just know that
the wrong side was Harding yes Harding
on the wrong side decades later Margo
Robbie immortalized the infamous gator
in itan a 2017 biopic that offers a
surprisingly sympathetic view of
Harding's life before during and after
the shocking event so here's the leadup
okay up next on the leadup ahead of the
1994 attack the Rivalry between carrian
and Harding was gaining steam
CH I'll do like where where appropriate
and where I can think of it I'll do
little little sounds that's why it's
great having you back okay the two
competed in the 1992 Olympic Games in
Albertville France where carrian took
the bronze medal just one step ahead of
Harding who came in fourth place okay
Harding was the favorite before the 92
games after she made history by becoming
the first American woman to land the
triple axelin competition during the
fall of 1991 she was never able to
perform it in competition again after
that year wow carrian on the other hand
became America's sweetheart after the
1992 games and W on to the sponsorship
deals and public Acclaim that eluded
Harding the two competed against each
other leading up to the 94 games as they
VI for a spot on the US Olympic team wow
so this has been bubbling okay now let's
get to it the
attack less than two months before the
games carrian was attacked at an Olympic
practice session in Detroit what was
Detroit as the cameras rolled it was
later found out that the cameras rolled
that's another thing what are you doing
galui yeah you're doing it in the place
and right on the knees and with the
cameras rolling doesn't make any sense
it was later found out that the as
salant Shane Stant had been hired by
haring's ex-husband gly and her
bodyguard sha Echo C though Harding Deni
knowing him the ESPN 30 for30
documentary series episode about the
attack wow no what's ESPN's all right I
forget I messed the attacker meant to
break carrigan's right leg to keep her
out of the competition but merely
bruised it despite I mean what a that's
I mean I mean this is a cluster could
you I mean yeah like you didn't even get
the job done it was like hitting her
with like a Fisher Price Club oh my God
despite her injury carrian famously went
on to compete in the 1994 games in ly
hmer Norway where she nabbed the silver
medal while Hardin came in eighth place
after having trouble with
lases karma is a be it is you see that
you came in eighth because of your
shoelaces and she came in fourth with a
bruised leg I'll tell you I'm not saying
I'm better than Shan stance but if I was
going to attack her with the billy club
that leg would have been broken 100%
following the attack media speculation
surrounded Harding and guli and they
eventually blamed each other in
interviews with the FBI guli accepted a
a plea bargain in exchange for his
testimony against Harding and spent 6
months in prison Stan eart and getaway
car driver Derek Smith also serve time a
host now as a getaway driver Jesus they
served time in prison for the attack
Harden long disputed her involvement but
was eventually convicted of hindering
the investigation into the incident she
received three years probation 500 hours
of community service and $160,000 fine
and was ultimately banned from the US
figure skating Association for life for
life for life now after now yeah now one
thing though did she have 160,000 did
she actually pay that out like shouldn't
she have gone to jail she should have so
are they saying she knew about it they
saying she knew them and knew after it
happened it didn't say whether she
helped conspire she that's the thing
with the law is like if you have a good
enough lawyer what's the thing with the
law the thing with the law is if you
have a good enough lawyer you don't have
to do anything ever that's just the
thing with the law right so okay carrian
was later inducted into the figure
skating Hall of Fame
and served as a special correspondent
during several Olympics it would be it
would be crazy if someone clubbed to
these days oh my God like what would
that be for that would be insane you
know like she got a double Club no one
gets a double Club over somebody might
do I mean copycat you're right you're
right for no reason just to other than
to be part of like maybe feel like what
it was like to be part of that right but
I would I would be like or just now
maybe they hearing us now and they're
saying what a wild sord it would be if
she got clubbed again and maybe that
this might Inspire somebody and then but
we're not going to jail for that we will
not we don't want to do that we're not
Galis over here I'm just pontificating
and extrapolating I ain't no gal here's
the thing so babe I have been preparing
for my comedy special and one of the
things that I was doing was trying to
get like make sure every night I get
good night's sleep MH because poor sleep
can lead to weight gain it can lead to
mood issues lower productivity and it
worked for me well I'll tell you what I
know for a fact that you've been using
beam Coco pow Dre beam dream powder to
get yourself cuz you are not fat your
skin looks amazing and you've just been
so personable lately that I was like
something's different and it's beam
dream powder and we've been talking
about this for a long time now the beam
dream powder okay it's it's uh their
healthy hot cocoa for sleep today our
listeners get a special discount on
beam's dream powder they're bestselling
healthy hot cocoa for sleep with no
added sugar now available in delicious
seasonal flavors like cinnamon cacao
which I've had sea saltt caramel I
haven't had and white chocolate
peppermint intrigued is it good I've had
it's amazing white chocolate
Peppermint's I think the best one all
right I'm going to share that next
better sleep has never tasted better
recent clinical study reveal dream
helped 93% of users wake up feeling more
refreshed and 93% reported that dream
helped them get a more restful night's
sleep if you want to try beam's
best-selling dream powder take advantage
of their biggest sale of the year and
get up to 50% off for a limited time
when you go to shop
beam.com heyab the discount is Auto
apply to checkout no code necessary
that's shop beam
beam.com Bape up to 50% off I'm doing it
I can't wait I want to try that white
chocolate pep try that baby
yeah I'm white chocolate pep in it um
it's a hey babe holiday on door Dash
folks I use door Dash in Chicago yeah
dude you can use door Dash any I love
door Dash because first of all the deals
they they they're just amazing the deals
they have are amazing and when you want
to just get when you're really craving
something you're like man I just need to
get something delivered to my mouth
right now door dashes to go to I here's
the reason I love it because we travel I
land in Chicago I don't know what's what
I pull up the door Dash app I'm getting
everything in in categories I'm getting
reviews I could make my own choice and
then it's places that don't normally
deliver there's this place called The
Little Goat Diner shout out in Chicago
oh I know that place you know it it's
amazing yeah it's so good and I I used
uh I ate there and then I was like I was
craving it again I door dashed little go
Diner to my uh bang Airbnb door and and
what they have they have this thing
called the dash pass member where you
can enjoy exclusive offers and perks all
season long you get a $0 delivery fee
and reduced service fees on eligible
orders if you're looking to save even
more the dash pass is the way to go yeah
these deals just started but they won't
last long shop holiday savings on door
Dash now use code hey babe holiday to
get 5 50% off up to a $10 value when you
spend $15 or more at a convenience
grocery or select retail stores on door
Dash because they don't just do
restaurants uh use code hey babe hey
babe holiday terms apply so from order
now and get the gift list the grocery
list and the other holiday Essentials
for Less with door Dash from December
1st to the 12th so Running Out of Time
use code hey babe holiday to get 50% off
up to a $10 value when you spend $15 or
more at convenience grocery or select
retail stores on door Dash again terms
apply so you said it so I'll say that
okay these deals just started but they
will not last long shop holiday savings
on door Dash now use code hey babe
holiday to get 50% off up to a $10 value
when you spend $15 or more at
convenience grocery or select retail
stores on door Dash terms apply the
former skater return to the spotlight
competing on season 24 of Dancing With
the Stars I missed that one miss that
one the married mom of three who danced
alongside you're ready for this artm
shis okay I would take that as em
chinvv I don't know what it is made it
to week seven in the popular television
competition I would think she was would
be a front runner because figure skating
and doing those flips and stuff she's
wholly athletic and her body is able to
go around and around yeah but if you're
not on Ice sometimes unless maybe she
charge you dancing with the stars with
her skates on on hardwood
flooring I tell you one thing I want to
know right now if we pull up up like you
know how they do those packages where
they show them uh rehearsing and
training and the Dancing with the Stars
do you think he held her like this and
she spun like a billion times in a row
if they didn't do that that's why she
lost the that's why she lost now GLI
actually changed his name to Jeff
Stone what if that said Greg
Stone and we uncovered it right now well
Greg Stone's real is not imagine his
name is Greg
guli guli changed his name to Jeff Stone
and receded from the spotlight though
itanya screenwriter Steven Rogers no
relation to Aaron told people he agreed
to be interviewed for the first time
since the incident for the movie eart
who later changed his name to Brian sea
Griffith died in 2007 from natural
causes at the age of 40 oh my God how do
you die from natural causes at 40 it's
karma it's karma it's karma it's Credit
Karma so for Harding life post Scandal
proved difficult according to a 2008
people profile Harding was arrested
twice once for a DUI once for an
attempted suicide how do you get
arrested for an attempted suicide I mean
everything she does is attempted that's
yes yes she can't close the deal this
woman that's what it is she can't get
the gold she can't break a leg and she
can't commit Su she's Tanya almost yeah
the couple welome in 2010 Harding wed
Joseph Jen's price she can't everybody's
got three names everybody's got the
everybody's got three names yeah
everybody the couple welcomed a son the
following year and Roger said Harding
like up whenever he's mentioned well I
should would hope so I would hope so
that's just a noral human lights up
meaning smokes crack or lights up
emotional right what is she yes I think
she was also in a homemade pornographic
uh um cinematic thing yes she was we'll
get to that next Harding roll that clip
Harding surprised fans and even Robbie
herself when she attended the LA film
premiere of itan the former skater was
seen wiping away tears as she posed with
Robbie on the red carpet like carrian
Harding also competed on Dancing With
the Stars appearing in season 26 oh I
mean it's right there if they were on
the same season that would have been the
I mean that would have been the the
highest ratings ever right people would
have been like waiting for it to happen
yes and then in season 26 four-week
event to 2018 featured only athletes
Harding was paired with Pro dancer Sasha
Farber and plays third overall wow the
best she's ever done she's never gotten
even into metal contention until dancing
with the stor but and oh yeah and oh
yeah third overall third get bronze and
although Harden continually denies her
involvement in the Scandal she has
remorse about the Carro Scandal of
course I feel guilty for what happened
she said in the 2008 profile but I can't
dwell I have to go on living okay it's
that the end of that babe is that the
end see here's the thing first of all
shout out Margo Robbie for playing
itanya and Barbie have you seen Barbie
by the way let me tell you something
right now s and I'm going to look in the
eyes so you know that I'm not lying to
you I I I want you to understand what
I'm about to tell you my daughters okay
my daughters Barbie let me tell you
something the movie Barbie I bought it
call it two months ago I have seen
Barbie I have seen the movie Barbie from
front to back can I guess can I take a
guess take a guess I'm not going to make
this up how long have you had it I've
had it for let's say two months okay and
what do you have it on digital like yeah
on Amazon Prime bought it own it they
know how to use the Amazon Prime or they
have to ask you uh the 8-year-old knows
how to do it the two-year-old has to ask
me the 2-year-old's first but the
2-year-old can ask the eight-year-old
she can ask the eight-year oldold then
it could be put on okay uh two months
ago I want to say that You' seen this
film I bet let me ask you one other
question do they ever watch it more than
one time in a day yes multiple times
almost every day of my life I'm
remembering my childhood now yep okay um
it ends and then it begins I'll say
you've watched it 57 times 65 times is
the final answer are you serious you Ser
I've seen 65 times from the beginning to
the end that movie if you have girls or
a gay son Barbie you will watch watch
that at all times always there is no
better and the thing about Barbie is
even now what's the thing about Barbie
it's it's a kids movie but it's for
adults like I can sit there and watch it
and I se I didn't think it was a kids
movie no yeah it it it's it's one of
those things where and now only on the
60th maybe the 50th let's call it the
50th time did you like oh that's Ryan
Gosling right that well no my daughter
my older one asked one of the Barbies
Harry nef is transgender she goes was he
born a man that one that Barbie I said I
was she born a man I said I think she
was I think she was born a man and then
she was like okay she goes that can
happen and I said I said uh yeah you
know that that's okay she goes like you
can just turn into a man I said what do
you mean she was like like is that like
something that can happen to like me
even like could I like turn into a man
and I said no I mean you have like it
doesn't just happen naturally you have
to get a surgery and I said did you know
that you have to get a surgery she said
no I thought that that could happen and
I'm like fair enough imagine we didn't
know and like at a certain point you can
just change and nobody knows the the
hand they dealt like you just grow into
it yeah like it's an evolution process
for a percentage of the population and
you didn't even you don't know until it
happens yeah wow I wonder how we'd all
feel and think then there yeah that's it
um yeah my young niece was watching I
walked in one time and she was watching
platoon then she turned to me and said
do we really need to be over there and I
was like we made the choice to be over
there we didn't I don't think we should
have been over there I don't think we
should yeah she said what exactly
happened there like atrocities and I
said where' you learned that word and
she said uh I I listen to you when you
talk yeah there you go yeah my um
it's Swift person of the year she
deserves it I was going to say no way
her
how what has she
done I'll tell you what I know she could
sell on four shows at the Vic she might
need a little extra help like I did yeah
uh which we did by the way so thank you
uh so let me ask you a question is she
GNA get a resounding um which she might
already have the contingent of but like
is there going to be any like are we' uh
what's it called back back uh backlash
Backdraft back gaming yeah she G to have
any back gaming from this she GNA get
she could she could get back gam from
this but I as I say too much right
that's what that's what they've been
saying since Biblical times haters going
to hate so haters going to hate I think
what Taylor Swift has done is never
really been done in music for me I'm not
and again that was that IC tea versus
316 to 318 yes that's what it was so to
each their own another Biblical quote
for me though when I'm watching a movie
or when I'm listening to a song I'm not
thinking about the writing and the you
know is it capturing this essence or
that Essence I'm just saying does it
make me feel good or not do I like it or
not I don't try to delve deep like I saw
the movie Napoleon and a lot of the
reviews where I didn't capture this
poing dynamite and and I was like you
know I I I liked it I just I thought it
was fine like it entertained me for 2
hours like what that's all this is I
feel like sometimes people take
themselves too seriously with it's like
stop trying to break down every single
one of Taylor songs just get just get
out there and start singing oh yeah I
just don't know I'm just saying like do
you like what do you do you feel how do
we feel about her on the whole H I don't
have an opinion but I mean like she is
is she the most famous hole I understood
is she the most
famous person in the history of the
world right now I would say in the
history of the world like not counting
Jesus and and the prophet Muhammad she's
got to be close right I would say right
now living breathing human beings Tera
Swift has to at least be in the top
three of most famous people I think the
most famous people in the world again
I'm just going to take a shot I'm going
to stand by it I think by name by visual
both like what do you think they are who
do you think they are I still think it's
Barack Obama oh oh really I still I just
think he was such an iconic figure
around the world I think it's I think
the three are Barack Obama Taylor Swift
and the Pope I think the pope is just a
religious figures are big Barack Obama
Taylor so like let's called Elon Musk
now he's up there but I don't think that
he's more famous than because you're
talking about like going into the deep
jungles of New Zealand do they know Elon
musos do they know Taylor
Swift well Michael Jack is she bigger
than Michael Jackson
no and speaking of Michael Jackson I
have something important to tell you
okay okay so Michael Jackson now granted
this isn't from the group chat this is
on Twitter there's a lot of speculation
going on pimp I know you're into
conspiracies with stuff like this
there's a lot of stuff going around that
Michael Jackson like is like was framed
for everything and really isn't really
isn't the the you know like with the
young kids and all that like really is
it he's like Roger Rabbit exactly
because here here we go here we go so so
so um wait this is just coming out now
why didn't it come out during the whole
Hub well no this because this is one of
those things where it's like getting to
the point now because of the internet
with all like you know what they say
like with the government like if you
mess with the 1% of the Illuminati or
whatever they'll like take you out so
this allegedly and yes I know there is
no real way to prove if this is AI or
not but supposedly according to all the
Twitter comments and according to
everything this really is Michael
Jackson's very last phone call with his
doctor okay this is his very last phone
call with his doctor and listen to what
he said first listen to this fart first
listen to this real fart that I did on C
that I that this morning walking my kids
to
school that's that o that's that's a
that's a questionable one here we go
this is June 24th 2009 Michael Jackson's
last phone call to his manager deer
Weisner he claimed that people were
after him and they were going to kill
him so here we go tell me if this is
true not true AI not not AI because then
this goes into a large conspiracy of
Michael
Jackson don't know if I should tell you
this but I don't know who may be
listening they may be a group of
people is it hard to hear okay all right
so let me read it then it's hard to hear
so let me let me read it so he's saying
I'll read what's wrong he he had AT&T
must have it I know Michael says I don't
know if I should tell you this I don't
know who may be
listening there may be a group of
people they want to get rid of
me they don't want me here
anymore I don't understand the doctor
says what do you mean talk to me to his
manager I
meant I can't talk about it he says on
the
phone I don't know what's going to
happen this is the day before his death
I'm running out of minutes I'm running
out of minutes in my
soul God knows they could shoot
me oh they could shoot me they could
stab me they could frame
me and say are overdosed on drugs he
didn't say that I swear to God he says
that's in the call here he says the last
Parts they could shoot
me they could stab me they could frame
me and say I'm overdosed on drugs the
day before his death now the thing is is
is that was that you know AI generated
was that real could that be a million
things but if that is real then it's one
of those because I think now What's
happen didn't he overdose on
drugs yes so if that was the last call
do you think maybe he could have been
high right but but it kind of feeds into
like like these conspiracies of like you
know like like you know like the
conspiracies with like um Chester from
Lincoln Park and uh and and um and the
guy from um the the lead singer who died
from sound garden Chris Cornell Chris
Cornell I didn't know there was any kind
of conspir there's a connection and then
one of them if you Google it there
always is a conspir I mean s's
mainstream famous enough have you never
felt the Illuminati presence in any
party or
anything you are the person in my life
that gets gives me the most anxiety that
I didn't have
beforehand no I don't I don't I where
would I have come across
illuminat I don't know I don't know
where the relationship begins I guess a
party or famous I don't I don't think
they basic cable I don't think they they
mess with right well they but the but
the connection between Chris Cornell and
and and Chester from Lincoln Park is
that and I think Anthony Bourdain is
they all died in the same way they were
all investigating child they were all
investigating um child sex trafficking
with like the government Hypes in the
government again this could all be
mean Google Google who was investigating
they were investiga like they themsel
like Google um uh Chester from Lincoln
Park Corell Chester from Lincoln Park
child sex trafficking uh you know
investigating yeah here we go I believe
that Chester Bennington from Lincoln
Park was murdered with Chris Corell an
article by spook yes
okay
um I mean it might be I don't know I
don't know the
I don't know the inde depths of the but
I'm I'm just trying to understand what
you mean about the the Child Welfare
that they were they were stumbling upon
real evidence of the government's
involvement or very powerful people's
involvement in child sex trafficking
because there's a rumor going around
that the elite or some people are
probably bangging their hands off the St
saying it's not a
rumor which whatever I don't know I have
no idea um so they they they're saying
that like child like you know like sex
trafficking is something that like the
very powerful of the world the 1% if you
will want to do that kind of stuff so
that they also thought that we were
ordering pizza and and ordering children
ordering stuff off of like a Wayfair and
order the problem is the problem is
every every conspiracy can be nullified
and then everything that we be think is
true can be nullified so you really
don't know what to believe ever but here
we go wait oh they were all working on
the same film together there it is so
the con the claim aichi can you scroll
up a little bit pimpy I'm sorry aichi
who passed away Chester Bennington
Anthony Bourdain and Cornell all died by
Suicide while working on the film silent
children so a year-old conspiracy that
recently gained traction on social media
is linking four celebrities deaths to a
long abandoned film Project isn't it
interesting that aichi Chester Benetton
Anthony Bourdain and Chris Cornell sick
what does sick mean when they do that in
parenthesis I always see that what does
that mean yeah I I think it means like
they they've extracted something from
right there I you know I should know
because I see it all the time and I I
forget I'm like inally so intentionally
so written but what ises that even what
does that
mean yeah I thanks for nothing Vena thus
in this manner so thus in this you're
getting further from my understand I
don't understand how is it applied oh I
like your new
balances um what's up guys Dr Squatch is
a new so product I've been using I got
sent These Bars because they're with the
podcast now and I have to tell you right
this second I love them I really do they
are they smell so they smell so good
there cool fresh aloe Bay Rum pine tar
they have all these cool scents wood
barrel Bourbon my favorite is Birchwood
Breeze this is what it looks like um
before I had before they sent me this I
really didn't have a soap that I would
use I have my regular soap this this is
definitely going to become my regular
soap um stuff to know about a high
performance natural products it's 98%
natural be corpse certified there's no
harmful ingredients um it just smells
great and it's a good holiday stocking
stuffer I'll tell you that much just
load this up in a stocking you buy three
soaps right now you get three soaps free
that's 28 bucks in savings that's like
getting each bar for $4 and this is like
a really kind of like artisanal type of
product there's free shipping that's
valid for new customers only uh yeah
right now Dr squash is offering our
listeners a huge savings all new
customers will get three free bar soaps
plus free shipping with any purchase of
three bars just go to drsquatch.com
heyab that's Dr Squatch drrs quu a
tch.com heab to receive this buy three
get three uh
offer uh slhe bab uh to buy three soaps
and get three free it's time to get all
the daily routine Essentials you'll need
to start feeling good and smelling like
a man today guys if you are uh serious
about your Oral Care like I am then
you're going to love quip okay one thing
big thing for me is I used to take a
regular toothbrush on the road with me
when I travel and do you know doing
comedy and going on the road this is
amazing because I get to bring the quip
travel toothbrush with me and it is
Electric Boogie wogie wogie so I love
having electric toothbrush with me on
the road it's a game changer okay they
also have this great water pick which I
use um trying to get my flossing habits
better so this water pick is really cool
they got the anti-cavity toothbrush
there's a whole Suite of products now
equipped when first when I first found
out about them I just got a toothbrush
and now they have everything they have
gum and mint they sell them in these we
fill in my gum and mins I put them in
this little dispenser it makes me feel
like a kid again
see it's fun
stuff um anyway good health starts with
good habits quip makes it Easy by
delivering all the Oral Care Essentials
you need to care for your
mouth for the toothbrush time Sonic
vibrations with 30 second pulses guide
guide you into a dentist recommended
two-minute clean you got to make sure
you get all two minutes in there um the
water flosser it hits all the right
spots it got gentle or deep clean
pressure at the touch of a button it's
extra wide it fits right under the
faucet and fills up in seconds uh the
mints in the gum every time you pop
those mints you'll be caring for your
mouth inside and out bold Mo flavor
helps keep your breath confidently fresh
and you get a boost of vitamin D which
we all need gum prevents cavities and
freshens breath when chewed for 20
minutes after eating so I usually use
the gum when I go out to eat it's
perfect if I can't brush after I eat um
the quip electronic toothbrush is loved
by over 9 million mouths in addition to
brush heads CP also offers the fresh
floss the toothpaste the mouthwash and
gum refills every three months for
$7 if you go to getquip.com heyab right
now you'll get 20% off any electric
toothbrush mint and gum dispenser or
water flosser that's your 20% that's 20%
of any electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser and get quip
if you guys go to getquip.com
heyab right now you'll get 20% off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser 20% off any
dispenser or water flosser at
getquip.com heab that's spelled
gqi
p.com equip the good habits company all
they all committed suicide while working
on a document called The Silent children
about widespread pedophilia trafficking
reads the text of a Facebook post shared
January 10th but the project was
canceled after Cornell's death so the
claim is okay now they're saying the
claim is wrong on several fronts DJ
producer aichi professional named Tim
burgling I see why he did it right
singers Bennington and Cornell and Chef
Bordain play imagine it's like DJ
producer aichi professional name Jeff
guli guli well so now they're saying
independent factchecking organizations
have noted that there is no connections
at all and Silent children was abandoned
5 years ago for issues unrelated to the
celebrities spokesperson said their
deaths occurred after the project was
already sh so we put that we put that to
bed so we put that to bed so a just
forget everything I said for the last
five minutes but it's just like things
like the thing is with the internet now
is like those things even like hearing
Michael Jackson's like like you know and
pimp you could probably speak to this
because you know the mo like AI can put
your voice in you wherever they want you
right now I don't know what this is
going to like like could could it like
right now pimp if you wanted to us you
could put our voice anywhere yeah the
the possibilities are endless and it's
going to get really crazy so the the
whole thing so the world doesn't get
destroyed is getting the software to to
make sure to be able to debunk and
recognize when something is artificial I
don't know otherwise if the truth goes
away then we are doomed who is it pick
it up from the Bible live on the Pod
football bids by
tonight football bids by tonight yeah
did you did you see this conspiracy
comparing Michael Jackson to the uh
Egyptian pyramid Sphinx they comparing
Michael Jackson the Egyptian pyramid
Sphinx now I haven't seen that one but I
mean I get it you know the Sphinx you
ever hear the conspiracy about the
Sphinx and the Egyptian uh you know like
stuff in the desert the Sphinx the Great
Pyramid of Giza that the Egyptians
didn't make those they discovered them
you ever heard that one yeah the
Egyptians just like stumbled upon it
yeah and that how they taking credit for
for the Aliens big salad right yeah
right that's a sefel reference but by by
the way Sal I made a salad yesterday you
ready for this spinach leaves cada
olives shout out uh ventia I call them
Vena olives camata yeah feta cheese
diced red onion yeah diced cucum sure um
oil vinegar cucum is a fun abbreviation
cucum I'm cuuming uh you're coming on Q
I'm coming on Q um sorry Q than God you
cleared out your office you basically
basically made a Greek salad Greek salad
but I was bracing cuz you said are you
ready for this let me talk to you though
about the Mediterranean diet if I could
have you for a moment yeah they say it's
the best right the Mediterranean diet I
mean it's what produces gods and
goddesses and the food though the food
though is fantastic like a little hummus
a little Peter not going to kill you not
going to kill I know that but I also you
know how I feel about hummus sometimes
it tastes like edible throw up it does
and it looks like it does look like my
2-year-old [__] yeah yeah depending like
some of it's good and then some of it is
not right do that make any sense
sometimes I have hummus I'm like this is
delicious hummus and then sometimes I
have and smell humus yeah not good the
one they give you on United in the box
of snacks oh my God it it makes me dry
heave every time I I open it like maybe
this time and I open it smells like
fresh vom yeah and then by association
it tastes like fresh vom by the way I
was on a flight you know how much we fly
prove it I
allegedly I was on a flight the worst
turbulence I've ever had in my life s i
was this close even though knowing
turbulence and all that knowing what we
know just kind of dealing with it I was
this close to texting Jasmine and be
like if something happens like just know
that I like have you ever gotten to that
well you did with the private plane told
me I did I did with that that one yeah
but on a commercial airline I've had
I've had terrible two or three times so
bad that I
was white knuckling the seed and and
trying to hold in my fears and tears and
stuff like that but the that other one
was like the the the the wheel didn't
come down we had the land but I know the
feeling I was I was I was reduced to
nothing nothing the pilot comes on about
2 minutes before I was flying on for
Phoenix 2 minutes before he goes um he
goes listen there's going to be some
turbulence we're going to go through
some turbulence it's going to be fine
but it's going to get really Rocky I
need the flight attendants all the
flight attendants to sit down in the
jump seats right now yeah so they stop
the service sit down which again I've
been on a million flights the thing that
was different about this one is I guess
I don't know if we had descended or what
was happening cuz we were still 2 hours
away from New York but the cabin
everything got dark because we were
flying through like a real rain cloud
where it was like dark in the cloud
almost like in the middle of like a
cloud like for some part of it was kind
of cool I'm like you're seeing like
little like shocks of electricity and
like lightning and I was like oh we're
in like a a mini rainstorm that I guess
they couldn't get out of the way of
right but the the it started to like get
like so violent we were you alone huh
alone alone we hit well I was with my
another guy with Mike Cannon but he
wasn't sitting next to okay so we hit
like an air pocket which you just like
drop a th000 feet and then the pilot
I've never I guess cuz like the pilots
are just even Beyond used to this he
came on the thing he was like who that
was a big one I swear to God he was like
laughing through it he goes oh that was
a big one trying maybe he's trying to do
his do his thing but like you know was
like people crying people like like
that like it's like you know it's one of
those things where like I got to be
honest with you I know air travel is
always been like tough I'm getting like
so so so sick of of the airports the
there's no like nobody's working in the
airports the TSA lines now if you have
clear or TSA pre-check the lines are
still 45 minutes they trying to sell I
heard they're trying to sell something
like extra clear clear plus cut the
clear line right so so I'm getting to
the point where I'm like you know like
like you ever get let me ask you this
this is the thing and this could be
applied to even people at home you ever
start to feel cuz you know in many
respects I would assume you're living
what you want your dream to be but do
you ever start to go through this and be
like this actually what I don't know
that this was my dream does that ever
happen to you where you're like I don't
know that I want to do this though yeah
or is that or is there just parts of
careers that some people like and some
people don't like like you think the NBA
player is even like you know what this I
don't want to I think human being I
think we put millions of hours into this
and I think sometimes your mind is going
to think about what what do I still want
to do this is I still hav funny you take
a little inventory what else could I be
doing I want to do this but when I start
to think about how there's no retiring
like that's when I when I start to think
about well how long am I doing this
right and because we we only make money
if we work right like I mean I mean
that's everybody else but I mean like we
have to like well we can control how
much we work and everything like that
right but also we can't like if if we if
we lose relevance or people don't want
us anymore then we're going to want to
we have to try to get as much work as we
can to get by right but we're in a
luckily a fortunate position where right
now we can dictate a little bit of the
frequency of the work and everything
like that but in know but it you know
how long does that last and then what if
you what if it stops before you want it
to stop or what if you like want it to
stop but you can't because you like you
know sometimes like I like you know
people that have a job that they don't
want to go to like they they clock in
they clock out they you know they don't
want to they don't take their work home
whatever they just like whatever but
like we can't do that right you got to
keep writing you got to keep performing
you got to you know you have to be a
certain level on stage so like I think
of that I think I'm like all right I'm
tired like I just finished like a
two-year tour and I'm about to start
another tour with the guys in a month
and before that tour I toured with them
like I toured with a year then six
months with them then six with me then
six month with them I'm going to do two
years with me so I don't stop touring
right and I I am like Jesus I
what if like should I become an Interior
Designer maybe right you know well like
like I would I almost like sometimes I
get jealous of like a nine to5 I envy I
should say right like a a nine to five
like I I because there's a beginning end
yeah I talk to my lady I'm like I just I
miss leaving my work uh at work and just
I get home I I get home at 5 6 o'clock
and I'm home and I have every night and
I have every Saturday and Sunday and I
miss things like going to the mall and
stuff like that like just I I'm like I I
told her I'm like I want to go like my
first day off like yesterday was my
first day I got back from Chicago and
I'm like I want to run errands all day
with it and we just went to go to CVS we
ran went and ran errands all day I was
like this is the best it's amazing I I
really mean that though I'm not being
prestigious like I I was like it's so
nice to just drive around like like and
just do like like a like you know the
regular schedule I used to have and just
remember what it was like to just like
you know like be able to just drive
around do erands now my time is consumed
with travel and so much I don't get to
do simple things like that that like
when you're doing them all the time it
might be annoying but like when you
never get to do anymore I kind of missed
I miss that's why like AR shafir
specifically has the greatest you know
he takes four months off and like gets a
flip phone and like goes away it's
unbelievable it's like it's like a
beautiful unbelievable what he does I
couldn't do that I couldn't be away from
family that long right but um put your
Christmas tree up yet I did I put it
up the Tuesday before Thanksgiving wow
How You Like Me Now real fake feroo I
had a uh 7even years ago when I moved
into my where I moved in I had a real
one and it was a lot of H and then I
went to Costco and I picked up this
pre-lit 9-footer things like butter man
dude I had it seven seven years now I
take it out I put it up you put the pole
inside the other pole it's like four po
four parts all the lights are already on
it lights up boom you got colored lights
or white lights and it falls into shape
my when we were younger do you remember
shaping the tree yes stepping it's bad
enough that you have a go step back well
not bad that's part of should be part of
the fun and put the the stuff on equally
but the shaping of the tree was was was
also a thing see I was see this is why
you don't you you got to just
communicate with friends because I was
going to sheepishly and embarrassingly
and kind of in a forgiving tone in an
asking for forgiveness tone tell you
that for the first time in my life for
me and my family we got a pre-lit tree
and I want to tell you that I'm sorry
that maybe you know that's you don't
condone that behavior and that's not
right and I'm taking the spirit of
Christmas away but my kids don't mind it
they like it they had fun putting it up
and all I have to do is press a button
and it goes on and off and it has made
my life so much simpler where it would
one now we have that tree in perpetuity
we can close it put it in a box put it
in the basement and I don't and they
will a tree in a Boxx Tree in a box
girl the my kids each have five
Christmas ornaments that they love and
they put each one of them up and it's
all good you streamline it bro I've
streamlined the the
prel it's a game changer you got to call
it for what it is does it take away from
a little bit of the tradition and the
process of that yes do I mind not
particularly these days my time is
limited and so anything can give me a
step ahead I'm all for the convenience
if I had more time would I want to be
more of a purist possibly got it does
that give you you really any answer
either way no no you're like Vena
reading the definition of sick didn't
help at
all didn't help at all and actually got
me further from the truth I knew I was
going to be gone to Chicago for a week
and I didn't want to come back in the
after the first week of December still
not having it up still looking forward
to doing that you go deep dish in
Chicago where'd you go luminati luminati
people say p luminati luminati but it
sounds like Illuminati pead PE quads
they say I want to try them they did one
of the people I haven't tried yet you
ready for this I went to the original PE
quads I did a show in Hammond Indiana a
month ago or two months ago it was me
Sergio shakon and my tour manager Tommy
uh AKA Tommy wheels and we go to PE
quads I call ahead they said we get your
ride in get your right in beautiful we
had a show we go in we're sitting there
guy comes over we're in we go uh you
know we'd like the pepperoni deep dish
whatever their famous one is he goes
it's about two hours for the pizza I
said but they seated you but I'm seated
they said yeah no we know you can get
appetizers but the pizza is just it's
going to take two hours and is that is
that the part for the course there like
people know no I I I I went to defaro
when it was busy and they were like it's
about a 45 to an hour minute wait for a
pizza right and I was like all right now
waited and it was worth it I I stood on
the street and ate it but like but the
two hours when you're there is they
don't let you know that I had time maybe
you people are in the know already or
was it just a particular night something
happened with the oven or no I think it
was like a s well it was a Saturday we
had a show at 7 2 hours 2 hours and then
you know what this is how good people
aren't there was a person next to us who
had waited two hours who got their Pizza
they had one slice left there was the
three of us they were like would you
like you boys like the the last slice
and you were like there's three of us
what what do you what do you even I was
like yeah how do I know want to fight
over it yeah exactly yeah you know so I
took out of billy club and I hit her
right in the knees exactly right I said
I'll do what GLI did that's right people
more people should do what guli did if
it's wor if it's if it's Justified I
think the name of this episode should be
what would GLI do
wwgd that's it what would GLI do that's
it so think about that we want you to
close your eyes right now and think
about a scenario you've been in recently
that you could have handled differently
or you needed advice and think about
what would Jeff galui do what would Jeff
Stone do what would guli do and also 71
neighborhoods of Chicago send it in one
breath you will get flown out to a hey
babe we'll take care of you but it has
to be 71 you cannot Miss A Beat and we
have the judges we have actually Tanya
Harding judging it yeah and if we
suspect Foul Play that you're reading it
we're not going to let you know but
there's going to be a BC waiting for you
you know what's going to happen you're
going to get G gal lead yeah yes all
right a big billy club a BBC BBC okay
all right God bless love BBC this has
been hey bab this has been hey
bab don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be a sh don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey babe